اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
بانوراما التي سانخصصها للحدث والحدث
مشاهدينا ومتابعينا هذا المساء هو اصدار
جديد لمايكل سنخصص هذه الحلقه لمناقشه هذه
الضجه وهذا الجدل وفي العناوين
لا تتنازل ابدا سادفع عن امريكا التي
احبها وخارجيا
لماذا وصف كوافير الامير محمد بن سلمان
بشخصيه تاريخيه على المسرح العالمي وبماذا
دفع عن العلاقات السعوديه الامريكيه
واعتبرها امرا يغيض بعض وسائل الاعلام في
واشنطن
وما هي الاسرار التي كشف عنها في كتابه
الجديد حول تصفيه سليمان وسارقه القرن
للارشيف النووي الايراني وما هو موقفه من
بيض وترامب وهل سيترشح للانتخابات القادمه
[موسيقى]
مذكرات وزير الخارجيه الامريكي السابق
واثاره الكثير من الجدل بشان ما جاء فيها
من معطيات سلطه الضوء على الكثير من
الاحداث المظلمه لا تتنازل ابدا القتال من
اجل امريكا التي احب هو الكتاب الذي كشف
من خلاله اسرارا اثناء قيادته
لوزاره الخارجيه في عهد ترامب سبعه عشره
قضايا مثيره حدثت خلال خبرته السياسيه
الطويله معتبره البعض بمثابه تمهيد لاعلان
ترشحه لانتخابات رئاسه المقبله حيث وصف
مراقبون ومن بينهم الكاتب الامريكي
يختلف تماما عن الكتب التي تطرح عاده قبل
الحملات الانتخابيه
في مذكراته التي تحمي العنوان لا تتنازل
ابدا دفاعا امريكا التي احبها تحدث وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي السابق ماي بومبيو في
الكثير من الامور ابرزها فلسفته مع اداره
ترامب التي شددت على حيويه وضروره العلاقه
القويه مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بومبيو في مذكراته دافع عن العلاقه مع
السعوديه بشده مشيرا الى ان علاقته
الدبلوماسيه مع المملكه كانت تغيظ بعض
وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه كما وصف السياسي
الامريكي ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد
بن سلمان بانه رجل اصلي وسيثبت انه احد
اهم قاده عصريه واشار الى ان ولي العهد
السعودي سيلعب دورا كبيرا وفعلا في توجيهه
ما وصاله السياسه الدوليه والاقليميه نحو
السلام والتنميه والازدهار في المرحله
المقبله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذا الموضوع مشاهدينا ومتابعينا معه
ضيوفنا هنا في الاستوديو عبد الله
صحفي السعودي اهلا بك من القاهره الدكتور
عبد المنعم سعيد عضو مجلس الشيوخ اهلا بك
ومن اورلاندو توم حرب رئيسه الامريكي
الشرق اوسطير الديمقراطيه اهلا بكم ضيوفي
الكرام وقبل ان نبدا النقاش لنتابع مع بعض
كيف تتفاعل رواد العصفور الازرق تويتر مع
التغريده التي نشرها
مع ولي العهد السعودي محمد بن سلمان والتي
تحدث فيها عن الذكريات والقصاص والمواقف
البناء هذه تغريده مشاهدينا جمعت ما يقرب
من اربعه ملايين مشاهده وهي الاكثر في
حيازه الاعجاب وكذلك عدد التعليقات عليها
واعاده تغريدها من بين كل تغريداتي حول
فيه الجديد
نبدا النقاش واسمحوا لي ضيوف الكرام ان
ابدا هنا في الاستوديو مع الاستاذ عبد
الله استاذ عبد الله اهلا بك معنا من جديد
واسمح لي ان ابدا معك من الموضوع الذي
يهمنا نحن كعرب صحيح باننا نتابع ومهتمون
بشؤون الدوليه ولكن شؤون العربيه تتصدر
بحديثه المملكه العربيه السعوديه السؤال
لماذا
هو الوضع الطبيعي لاي سياسي امريكي همم
يرى المشهد الدولي على حقيقته وهذا الامر
ليس جديدا هذا هو الاصل في العلاقات
السعوديه الامريكيه منذ عده عقود الذي غير
الذي تغيره هو الانحراف الذي سادس السياسه
الامريكيه لمده ثمان سنوات او عشر سنوات
باتجاهات جديده على السياسه الامريكيه
نفسها جعلت من السعوديه والدول العربيه
همم خصوما بدون مبرر وتخلت عن في امريكا
لما جاء الرئيس ترامب عادت امريكا الى
نفسها مجددا وحاول ان تبني علاقات جديده
في العديد من الملفات حول العالم اتجاه
السعوديه واتجاه ايران وتجاه منطقه الشرق
الاوسط واتجاه صراع الدولي مع روسيا ومع
الصين ومع غيرها حديث بومبيه وهو حديث مهم
لانه رجل همم وزير خارجيه في عهد ترامب
وكان رئيس فهو مطلع على العديد من الملفات
الحساسه جدا
بتفاصيلها وبالتالي فهو يتحدث عن المعرفه
وهو يمثل رجالات اميركا الكبار كمسؤولين
وكمحللين استراتيجيين الذين كان يرون
السعوديه كحليه في استراتيجي على مدى عقود
من الزمن وبالتالي هو متسق مع نفسه ومع
امريكا ومع معطيات الواقع اليوم التي تقول
ان السعوديه هي دوله رائده وقائده في
المنطقه وفي العالم برؤيتها الجديده
وبمكانتها الجديده وايضا بيرثها القديم
وبالتالي هو عمر طبيعي ولذلك احتفى به
الناس داخل امريكا وخارجه
كنا تبعنا هذه التغريده التي لقت تفاعل
كبير بالمقارنه حتى مع بقيه تغريدات تتحدث
عن ااا متانه العلاقه السعوديه الامريكيه
هو كذلك تحدث هو خاصه بحديثه ولي العهد
السعودي وهنا السؤال حذرتك دكتور عبد
المنعم ما الذي اراد قوله
لما تحدث ليس فقط هو لم يشد فقط بشخص ولي
العهد السعودي وانما تحدث عن المستقبل
وقال بان التاريخ سيذكر بانه شخصيه ستكون
من ابرز واهم القاده في العالم
يعني هو بومبيه في هذا الكتاب في الحقيقه
بيقوم بالرده على امور كثيره في تقييم
الوضع في السعوديه والوضع ايضا في في
المنطقه هنا
طبعا المدرسه التي ياتي منها بومبيه وهي
مدرسه الواقعيه كما قال تقريبا نصا انه ان
يكون المدرسه الواقعيه هي ان يكون الشعب
الامريكي اكثر اهميه من السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه التي عاده ما تكون تاخذ شكل
تبشيري مثالي همم ايديولوجي على الاغلب في
التطبيق ده محتاج نظره واقعيه لقياس ما
يحدث في المنطقه وان هناك عمليه اصلاحيه
كبيره تجري في المنطقه همم مركزها الاساسي
حاليا للمملكه العربيه السعوديه او توجد
بقوه شديده في المملكه بتغير من اوضاع
اقتصاديه واجتماعيه
وثقافيه كثيره همم
المملكه لسنوات طويله وعقود طويله كانت
هناك كثير من
المحافظه الشديده همم
والانغلاق النسبي على العالم رغم وجود
الحج والعمره قادما من عالم الاسلامي لكن
الانفتاح الجديد في السعوديه فاتح للعالم
كله همم على استعداد للحوار مع العالم كله
ال- ال- الحديث هنا في كلام بومبيه هو
الاصلاح والتحديث الموجود والتحديث ابعاده
كثيره في داخل المملكه سواء من الناحيه
الجغرافيه انتشار العمران تغيير البنيه
الاساسيه عمليه التنوع في همم الثروه داخل
التي تدخل المملكه كل هذه الامور همم
واضحه همم ويتشكر رساله ايضا همم من
بومبيه للمواطن الامريكي حول اختيارات
والمقبله هل يكون ذلك في اتجاه نفس
المدرسه
الاوبماويه التي كانت يعني تنظر للعالم
بنوه معين من التبشير او انه يكون نوع
واقعي همم يعني هنا هو كمان يريد ان يسجل
انه من مدرسه ترامب حتى ولو كان يعني لا
يفضل ان ترام ترامب يدخل الى الساحه بعد
ان اخذ فرصته همم من قبل وان البديل
الواقعي له في هذه الحاله هو بومبي نفسه
ههه
لانه كانه كتب الكتاب قبل اعلان ترامب
ترشحه فلنعلم الحسابات كيف ستكون كذلك في
هذه المرحله ولكن عن ما كانت هذه العلاقات
وما تفضلت به دكتور همم عبد المنعم همم
لديه بعض نظر وقارئ جيد جيد ل همم
التغيرات السياسيه وحتى لواقع الدول
لتتحالف او المتحالفه تاريخيا مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه همم سيد توم همم ما
الرساله او هل هناك رساله للخارج فقط او
هناك كذلك رساله للداخل كان يريد بابيو ان
يضمنها في كتابه
هو متخرج من افضل جامعه للضباط في
الولايات المتحده عمل
نائب في القواس الاميركي لفتره وبعد ذلك
كان رئيس المخابرات الامريكيه وزير
الخارجيه وهو انسان
في الكونجرس اما في الجيش راى اداره
الرئيس اوباما في السابق كيف احتضنت
مجموعتان اساسيتين من الشرق الاوسط اول
مجموعه هي قوه ضغط للنظام الايراني في
الولايات المتحده وكذلك الاخوان المسلمين
الذين تعشوا وتغلغل في جامعات الولايات
المتحده وبداوا وعناصر قويه ضمن الحزب
الديمقراطي وما كان ينصحون
ويتمنون على اداره اوباما ان تف في الشرق
الاوسط ونسيت اداره اوباما زملائها
التقريبيين في الشرق الاوسط من السعوديه
ودول الخليج وحتى فتره في مصر كيف نشا
الاخوان المسلمين واستلموا النظام في في
مصر فكل هذه همم كانت في فتره همم
بامبيوكانا ممثلا عن ولايه كانسس في
الكونجرس الامريكي فعرف خطوره المعامله في
السياسه الخارجيه من هذا المنظار وعندما
وصل الى رئاسه ارسي اي اي طبعا كان له
معلومات هائله كيف حصل ما حصل بعد الرئيس
اوباما انت من الاخوان المسلمين اما من
تيارات همم النظام الايراني في واشنطن ثم
اداره اوباما وكان ولعب دور اساسي في
اداره الرئيس ترامب وهو الرئيس ترامب شيخ
مباشر ماذا يجب العلاقه تكون السعوديه
ولكن الاهم من كل هذا هذا انه شخصيه ولي
العهد محمد بن سلمان انه ليس وعد
بالاصلاحات وان مقام بالاصلاحات وهذا كان
شئ اساسي لتغيير جذري عند اداره الرئيس
ترامب في ذلك الفتره والعلاقه المتينه
الذي راوها بشخصيه ولي العهد استاذ عبد
الله لنكون اكثر ربما واقعيه كذلك وصادقين
مع هذه المرحله وما تشهدها سنقول بانه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه همم لديها مصالح
وهي كذلك يعني ليست لديها مشاكل همم او
اختلافات عميقه مع ال- ال- الحكومه
الحاليه مع البيت الابيض حاليا ما حكومه
بعدين كذلك قادره على التعامل وعلى همم
اداره شؤونها واداره مصالحه ذلك ولكن لما
يريد ان يبرز بان همم هناك حقبه لا يمكن
ان تسقط من هذه العلاقه المتينه بين
الثنائي ما الذي كان يود قوله بالتحديد هو
بالتحديد يرد على توجه في السياسه
الامريكيه الحاليه والسابقه مع عوامه يرد
على
ما تحول له الحزب الديمقراطي الامريكي مع
الاباميه سواء في عهد اوباما لفتين او في
عهد الحالي وهو يرد على هذه التوجهات
السياسيه التي لعبت كثيرا في توازنات همم
او في تحالفات امريكا حول العالم وفي
دوريها حول العالم رؤيه انسحابيا رؤيا
انعزاليه عن العالم ورؤيه عادت حلفاء
امريكا ووضعتهم في مواقف حرجه ولذلك عندما
جاء ترامب لاربع سنوات وجد الكثير من
الدعم
لتوجهاته وهو اختار عن واعي ان تكون
زيارتها الخارجيه الاولى للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه وهو يجتمع اكثر من مره مع ولي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
وبمبي وهو احد رجالات همم
طيب اداره ترامب وبالتالي هو يريد ان يرسل
رسائل ان هذا هو الامتداد الطبيعي للسياقه
التاريخي للسياسه والتوجيهات الامريكيه
بخلاف الشذوذ الذي حصل وربما يحصل بعض
الان
المواقف السياسيه التي اتخذتها السعوديه
في عهد الملك سلمان حفظه الله بقياده سمو
الامير محمد غيرت في توازين في موازنات
القوه حول العالم وهذا امر يعيش صانع
القرار في البيت الابيض جيدا ويتحدث عنه
بصراحه وهو يرسل رسائل للسعوديه وحلفائها
في المنطقه وحول العالم ان امريكا اذا
اصبح له نصيب ان ان يكون له دور في
المرحله المقبله اذا ما همم ترشح للرئاسه
سيعيد هذه العلاقات وسيعيد بناء العلاقات
من جديد بعيدا عن اي انحرافات حدثت من
ادارات همم مختلفه والسعوديه ترحب بهذه
السعوديه اليوم
قالت لامير في اكثر من موقف سواء في الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه في اسعار النفط في
العلاقات الاستراتيجيه مع الصين ان
البدائل في العالم موجوده ولكننا لا نتخلى
عن حلفائنا في امريكا السعوديه لم تتخلى
عن امريكا على الرغم من كل التصريحات
والمواقف التي لا تبتسم بالوديه تجاه
السعوديه ولكنها لم تتخذ مواقف في مقابلها
ولكن خيارات مفتوحه وقد تضع هذا مع
الاحداث ومع القرارات ومع المواقف طيب على
كلن كما تحدث بصدق شديد وكما قال على
الاقل على الجانب العربي على المملكه
العربيه السعوديه تحدث كذلك بصدق جديد على
ملف الاخر وهو ملف ايران همم سن تابع هذا
الموضوع مشاهدينا فبخصوص الملف الايراني
تحدث في مذكراته على العديد من الجوانب
بدايه من ثوره الايرانيه التي كانت في عام
1970 وصولا الى تصفيه قاسم سليمان وكيف
ساعد في نامي عمليه سرقه القرن عندما قام
عملاء تابعين للمصاب بالاصطلاح على
الارشيف النووي الايراني حيث قال ان
النظام الايراني طور من نسخه خلال العقود
السابقه واصبح القوه الكامنه وراء شبكه من
الجماعات الارهابيه التي تسيطر عليها
ايران في العراق ولبنان وسوريا واليمن كما
هاجم الاتفاق النوويه الايراني
اوباما وقال على المستوى الاستراتيجي كانت
خطه العمل المتعلقه بالاتفاق النووي اا
غيبت او غيبت بشكل كبير وكشف اعطيه
وتفاصيله اتخاذ القرار قتل قاسم سليمان في
بغداد مطلعه 2020 من قبل الرئيس السابق
ترامب ومسؤولين في ادارته والتي اعتبرها
هدفا عسكريا مشروعا
والمحبوبي في كتابه الجديد الى ان وكاله
المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه ساعدت عملاء
المصادقه على الفرار من ايران في فبراير
2018 10 بعد ان نجحوا في سرقه ارشيف ايران
النوويه
[موسيقى]
عود من جديد الى ضيوفي اسمحوا الان اعود
من القاهره معك دكتور عبد المنعم دكتور
عبد المنعم من بين كل النقاط التي ذكرها
في كتابه والتي لها صله بايران ان كان عن
سرقه القرن عن مقتل قسم سليماني او عن
توصيفه كذلك لنظام الايراني هو نقاط اخرى
ما الملف او ما النقطه التي فاجاتك ان صحت
عبير اكثر او التي تستوقفتك اكثر من غيرها
يعني الحياه كل الكتاب وما فيه يعني
يستوقف في امور كثيره لكن هنا في النقطه
الخاصه بايران على وجه التحديد يلتقي وزير
الخارجيه مع رئيس المخابرات المركزيه
الامريكيه في في اطار واحد
بحيث يذيع اسرارا اييي لم اكن اتوقع ان
اجدها في هذا الكتاب خاصه
الايراني
بالطبع ايران تعرف ان هذا الملف في سرق
منها يعني انما نشر ذلك على العالم على
انه كان عمليا
مخابراتيه امريكيه اسرائيليه همم ربما
ايضا يحمل بعض التحذيرات نحن نعرف ان نقوم
به هناك او الان خارج السلطه همم يعني هو
يعني يتحدث الى الشعب الامريكي في ال- في
الاساس لكن ايضا يتحدث
هو خارج السلطه ولكن ان يعود لها وهنا
كذلك حسابات اخرى قد تتعلق بامكانيه هذه
العوده
يعني قوه كثيره في المنطقه لانه هو كان
جزء من تيم من فريق كامل بيرقصوا الرئيس
ترامب بيعبر عن فلسفه معينه هيبقى مثيره
قوي ان نعرف ما الذي سوف يحدث بين بومبيه
وترامب خلال المرحله المقبله لانه كما
ذكرت فانه ترامب اعلن مبكرا جدا للترشح
للرئاسه همم كثيرين في الولايات المتحده
هيلمونه على ذلك البومبيه يريد ان يملا
فراغا ربما سوف يتركه همم ترامب
ويملا هذا الفراغ بقوه شديده عن اعمال
فعليه فعليه باشرها يعني موضوع ال- ال-
الملف موضوع ايضا انه همم قاسم سليمان لكن
ان يقول ببساطه شديده ويعلن بقوه انه
قاعده مكانها ليس افغانستان وانما مكانها
الحقيقي هو ايران هذا توصيف ليس معتادا
على على الاطلاق
واعتقد هو فيه كثير من الحقيقه لانه يوجد
داخل ايران بالفعل بعد سقوط افغانستان
انتقل كثير من القاعديون الى ايران همم
خاصه اسريهم
واقيموا فيها وبالتاكيد كانت لهم علاقات
قويه مع المخابرات الايرانيه همم كل هذه
الامور يعني تلقي اضواء جديده على احداث
حدثت من قبل لكنها ايضا تقول لنا من هو
الرجل الذي يكتب هذه المذكرات وهو يقدم
نفسه على ان على انه الشخص الذي يدافع عن
مصالح ال- المواطن الامريكي ولا يريد ان
يكون تبشيريا خارج الولايات المتحده
مقتل قسم سليماني بسؤال بسؤال لك استاذه
توم هو في الواقع لما تحدث عن مقتل قاسم
سليماني لم يتحدث فقط عن التفاصيل ولكن
تحدث خاصه عن كيف تم اخذ القرار وقال بان
القرار وهذا لا نعلم الى اي مدى سيستفز
كذلك الجانب الايراني قال بان القرار اتخذ
في خمس دقائق همم انا الذي طرحت هذه
الفكره على ترامب وقلت له بانه هذا يهدد
الامن القومي وهذا متورط في مقتل امريكيين
فاخذ من الموضوع خمس دقائق همم اخذ قرار
مقتله هذه النقطه الى اي مدى قادره ان
تستفز النظام الايراني اكثر من عمليه
القتل نفسها بانه همم من اكبر قادتكم همم
اخذ منها خمس دقائق همم
نتحدث عن مصيره او نقرر مصيره
الامريكيه وخاصه اداره ترامب تكلموا عن
تصرفات النظام الايراني في اليمن في لبنان
في سوريا
التخطيطات التي يقوم بها قاسم سليمان قتل
المواطنين الامريكان وجنود الامريكان في
في العراق لفتره طويله وبعدين وكان يحضرون
لربما
ضرب قاعده امريكيه اما نشطاء امريكيين
يقدر بحواله ال 500 شخص على ما قال همم
سيد
ولكن اتخاذ القرار انه هذا المناسبه لانه
كان هنالك ثلاث طيارات مسيره بالاجواء
كانوا يعرفون انهم انتقل من سوريا الى
بغداد كان هنالك تحضيرات على الارض
باشخاص منكرين
برجاء بعمال صيانه واتخذوا القرار بقتله
بالوقت الحاضر يعني اعطاء الامر بقتله
الان وليس انه اذا كان قرارا اي اذا يجب
ان يقبل سليمان ولا لا لانه يعتبرون س-
سليمان من القاعده العسكريه الايرانيه
لتنفيذ لتنفيذ الهلال الشيعي في الشرق
الاوسط وتدمير الشرق الاوسط دوله استاذ
عبد الله في حديث عن النظام الايراني كان
همم
صريح واستعمل عبارات ربما يقوله مراقبوني
اول مره تستعمل من مسؤول همم في منصبه
ربما فاسمح لي ان انقل لك ما الذي قال لا
افهم منك التوصيف ما الذي كان يريد منه
لما تحدث عن النظام الايراني قال فالواقع
النظام الايراني هو جماعه ارهابيه لم يقل
دوله ترعى الارهاب هو جمع ارهابيه ولكن
بخلاف غالبيه الجماعات الارهابيه هذه
الجماعه تمتلك ادوات فن الحكم حدود
دبلوماسيه عمله مصارف الى اخره هكذا
تصريحات كيف يتلقاها النظام الايراني
التوصيل الذي يطرحه
لايران نحن نعرفه في المنطقه جيدا
وبتفاصيل دقيقه جدا ربما لا يدركها بومبي
ولكن الاهميه ان شخصا في مثل مكانته
ومنصبه ويدرس الرسائل الشعب الامريكي
ويرسل الرسائل لقواعد الحزب الجمهوري في
الشعب الامريكي مهم ان يقول هذا الكلام
وان هذه الدوله هي عباره عن جماعه ارهابيه
وتنظيم ارهابي
امتلك دوله فاصبح عنده ما يشبه الدوله
لديه برلمان وحدود وجيش
وخلافه يوحي للناس بانه يمتلك دوله ويمثل
نظام شرعيا بينما هو في حقيقته تنظيم
ارهابي وايضا نقطه مهمه ان يدرك مثل
بومبيو ان العلاقات بين الاصوليه
الاسلاميه والجماعات المتطرفه في الاسلام
كسرت الحدود بين التقسيمات المذهبيه
فالاسلام السياسي السني والشيعي هما يعني
وجهان لعمله واحده ولذلك لم يكن مفاجاه ان
ان ان يكون تنظيم القاعده كما قالوا
كمكتشفهم بيودر من طهران وتنظيم داعش ايضا
يدار من طهران وكل الجماعات الاسلام
السياسي سواء بالاخوان المسلمين او في
حماس او في همم حزب الله او في السروريين
في السعوديه تخيل يعني ان اشخاص من رموز
التيار السروري والاسلام السياسي في
السعوديه متشددين
عقائديا يبررون
لايران كل خيارات لتنظيم القاعده الدينيه
ان يتحالفون مع ايران ضد السعوديه وضد
الدول العربيه هي منظومه اصوليه معاديه
للدول وعندما يتحدث عن تشكل وعيه اتجاه
هذا النظام بتفجيرات
الايرانيه للجنود الامريكيين في
لبنان ايضا يتحدث عن التفجيرات في
السعوديه فهو يتحدث عن شواهد صغيره جدا
الخارجيه السعوديه اصدرت قبل بضع سنوات
قائمه مطوله بكل الجرائم الارهابيه التي
عرفتها النظام الايراني ضد الامريكيين ضد
دول المنطقه
السؤال الاستاذ عبد المنعم استاذ عبد
المنعم يعني لما يتكلم
بهذه الصراحه همم بهذه الجراه يقول البعض
هو لم يوصف فقط النظام هو قال بانه همم
طعم او طهران هي معقل القاعده مثلا الا
يحسب يوما اخر او لا يحسب حساب يوم اخر
اذا معاد
للحياه السياسيه كفاعل اساسي داخل البيت
الابيض مثلا همم كيف يفكر في هذا الاطار
انا اريد ان اثير نقطه هنا انه هو بالفعل
بهذا الكتاب
يقوم بدور معين في السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه ايا كانت انتقادات لها لانه
كتاب لرئيس للمخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه
السابق وزير الخارجيه السابق لابد ان يمر
على الاجهزه المعنيه داخل الولايات
المتحده هنا هذه الاجهزه ترى ما يؤثر وما
يضيف وما يساعد الامن القومي الامريكي في
هذه النقط ليست همم محض
للمناقشه ولكن سمح بها من قبل
الوكالات والمؤسسات
المعنيه بهذا الموضوع واعتقد انه هنا
الاشاره القويه جدا من الاداره الامريكيه
الحاليه همم للضغط على ايران خاصه وان
هناك عوامل كثيره يمكن فيها التاثير لانها
مرتبطه بالوضع الداخلي في ايران الذي هو
سيء جدا على المستوى السياسي والاقتصادي
والاجتماعي هو ايضا يظهر همم النظام
الايراني بانه عاجز عن حمايه وثائقه وانه
في الحقيقه ليس نظاما تبشيريا مؤيدا
للاسلام وانما هو متعاون مع قوه ارهابيه
عنيفه همم يرى معظم العالم الاسلامي انها
لا تعبر عن الاسلام الصحيح انه رساله ايضا
وهن لكثير من يعني نقدر نقول بصراحه عملاء
ايران الموجودين في عديد من الدول العربيه
ويحاولوا ان هم يدافعوا عنها باشكال همم
يعني متعدده فاذا هناك جزء من السياسه
الامريكيه في هذا الكتاب لكنه ايضا في في
النهايه هو يعني ممثل لشخص هو احد
المرشحين حاليا من قبل على الاقل الاعلام
امريكي يعني يكون في طليعه
المشاركين في الحمله الانتخابيه القادمه
عن القادم سنتحدث بعد قليل معك استاذ توم
حرب عن هذا القادم المنتظر هل سيترشح لن
يترشح فبخصوص فتره عمله مع الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب كشف وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
السابق انا اداره ترامب بانت سياستها
الخارجيه على مبدا بسيط وهو السلام من
خلال القوه رافضا منطق بوتين الذي وصفه
باستخدام التفوق السيكولوجي من خلال
الفظاظه وبخصوص الرئيس الامريكي الحالي
وسلسله القرارات التي اتخذها منذ ان تولى
رئاسه اعرب وزير الخارجيه الامريكي السابق
عن قلقه من سياسات بيضا وعودته للسياسه او
للسياسه الرئيس الاسبق اوباما فيما يتعلق
بعده قضايا ابرزها الملف النووي الايراني
وايضا عجز اداره رئيس الحاليه عن معالجه
العديد من القضايا في الداخل الامريكي
بدايه من رائحه كورونا وصولا للتضخم
والركود الاقتصادي الذي تشهده البلاد
وتابع من جديد معك استاذ توم استاذ توم هل
همم بهذا الكتاب يروج
لربما امكانيه ترشحه للانتخابات القادمه
لشخصيه مثل
وتكلم عن نجاح اداره الرئيس ترامب واداره
الرئيس ترامب لانه كان بالفعل الرئيس
ترامب هو اللي عنده كان سياسي واضحه موجه
في جهه داخل الامريكي وتجاه دول العالم
كله وقته وهؤلاء الاعمده منهم وزير
الخارجيه
لينفذ ويساعد الرئيس ترامب على سيادته هذا
كانت سياسه ترامب وليست سياسه
اداره ترامب بسبب الاعمده عند الرئيس
ترامب وطبعا كانت فشل سياسه اوباما في
السابق تجاه الشرق الاوسط وعده مناطق وحتى
الان فشل سياسه الرئيس
بالسياسه الخارجيه يعني قبل ما اجى الرئيس
سيسبب الحروب وكان هذا بالعكس تماما
الرئيس ترامب اتى وصار في تصاعد بمفاوضات
الاقتصاد والازدهار والتجاره والميزان
التجاري بين الدول العالم ما اذا كان ذلك
من مشاكل حلب باي منطقه كان لها نهايه
الرئيس بيدن اليوم شفنا الحروب نشات
انطلقت باوكرانيا الوضع المتازم بين الصين
وتايوان وعدت مناطق اليوم في العالم
العربي عم تغلي غاليه من وراء هلا الرئيس
[موسيقى]
عملاء انا يعني بتصور من المحتمل ولكن
كلهم بيخوضوا معركه الانتخابات لا يحصلوا
على مراكز جديده بمن سيربح الانتخابات
التمهيديه في الجمهوري
هل ترى بان فتره في البيت وعلى الاقل
وزيرا لخارجيه ترامب كانت فتره همم سياسيه
تونس التراب او قرارات اهمها وابرزها تنسب
كذلك لمهندس دبلوماسيتو وهو بومبو
لانبوبيه وكذلك في كتابه تحدث عن ان همم
القرارات التي اعتبرها البعض همم عشوائيه
ارتجاريه اتخذها ترامب هي في الواقع
قرارات كانت مدروسه وكانت تاخذ بعين
الاعتبار المتغيرات الجو السياسيه همم
وبالتالي هذه التصريحات هل يروج بها لنفسه
او يروج بها او يصحح بها نظره البعض ترامب
يعني علينا ان نعرف ان البومبيه كان
موجوده طوال مده وجود ترامب في السلطه
يعني اربعه سنوات كامله اللي هي الفتره
التي قضاها الرئيس ترامب في موقعي كان
بومبيه معه في واحده من المؤسسات الاساسيه
وهي وكاله المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه
ثم وزاره الخارجيه وعضو دائم في البرنس
بيلز الخاصين بمجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي فهو شخصيه مهمه واعتقد انه لو
نرجع حتى للدفاتر القديمه ان اختيار
بومبيه وعمل لحظه فريقه لانه كثير من
المسؤولين الذين تعاملوا مع ترامب تركوه
في منتصف المده او احيانا بعد شهور همم
قليله يعني وزاره ترامب يعني اداره ترامب
كانت من الادارات القلقه انما بومبيه كان
جزءا ثابتا وهمم وقويا داخل نظام اداره
واا اداره ترامب
ويبدو انه هو كان احد المفكرين الاساسيين
فيها واحد المنفذين ايضا الاساسيين فيها
لانه يستطيع ان يفهم ما الذي يريد ترامب
وظيفه الرئيس دائما ان يضع الاتجاهات
العامه وفلسفه السياسيه لكن بيحتاج الى
كثير من
المحترفين الذين يستطيعون ان يحولوا هذه
الرؤى الى واقع بمبي وكان من القيادات
الرئيسيه لاداره ترامب بلا شك هل يكون هو
امتداد له مره اخرى همم هذه قضيه اخرى
يعني علينا ان ننتظر
هل سيتركه ترامب هل يكون مطيع استاذ عبد
الله ان تتحدث منذ قليل عن انا بابو يتحلى
بالواقعيه بالبراغماتيه هل هذه الواقعيه
ستجعل منه مساندا
ابقى طموحه للرئاسه قد يجعلنا نكتشف وجها
اخر له ربما في الايام القادمه
بعد
معركه الرئاسه الامريكيه وبالذات داخل
الحزب الجمهوري ترامب اعلن ترشحه هناك
شخصيات اخرى تعد نفسها للترشح من ضمنهم
ونحن في المنطقه سنتعامل مع الرئيس الجديد
ايا كانوا مع المرشح ايا كان ولكن انا
اعتقد لو ترامب دعم في رئاسه امريكا ستكون
حظوظها قويه جدا وسيمثل امتداد حقيقي
اذا حدث شيء همم غير متوقع همم ولكن في
النهايه نحن لا يهمنا صراحه سواء كان
الرئيس من الحزب الجمهوري او الديمقراطي
نحن تهمنا في المنطقه مصالحنا ومصالحنا في
هذه المرحله التاريخيه هي مع الحزب
الجمهوري وليست مع الحزب الديمقراطي
بصورته الحاليه والا كانت مصالح كبرى مع
الحزب الديمقراطي والجمهوري على مدى سنوات
طويله ايا كان المترشح فقد تغيرت موازين
القوه في المنطقه وفي العالم وهي اخذها في
التغير ومن الافضل ليامريكا ولحلفائها بما
فيها نحن في المنطقه ان تتجه الامور
والاستقرار السياسي والاعاده الامن
والاستقرار والتنميه والازدهار العالم
بعيدا عن اي مغامرات في حروب او في صراعات
دوله دوليه راينا قبل سنه انها كادتا تسقط
النظام الدولي بسبب الرغبه العارمه في
معاقبه روسيا في موضوع الحرب الالكترونيه
المطيع كذلك لهذه القرارات بما يتناسب مع
السياسه التي يؤمن بها اكيد ولكن هل يمكن
لبابا على عكس مثلا جون بولتون الذي كشف
وترامب في السلطه وكشف اسراره وفضحه وحتى
البعث قال بانه همم هو الذي افشل همم
مباحثاتنا مع كوريا الشماليه ولكن ااه
بومبيو مغير له ف- هل تعتقد بانبيو قادر
اني واصل في نفس هذه المسيره ان يدعم
الحزب ان يدعم القائد ام ان لحسابات
الرئاسه او للرئاسه حسابات اخرى
يعني نحن قادمين على فتره انتخابيه
ونرحب بكل المرشحين بالحزب الجمهوري وطبعا
راح نقعد ناخذ فنجان قهوه ونراقب مرحله ست
سبعوري وحتى الان هو المرشح الوحيد حتى
هذه اللحظه في الحزب الجمهوري وكان امبارح
ومحطه ثانيه بسوس كارولينا
المهم انه لينسيجرام هو سنه مهم كثير
بالحزب الجمهوري دعم ليله امس المرشح
ترامب وهو كمان بنفس الولايه كان فين
ولايه ميكي هايله اللي هي كمان كانت
مبعوثه لا همم ترامب الى الامم المتحده
وكمان من المفترض انه تترشح يعني سقط
الترشيح امبارح بدعم همم بدعم السيناتور
للرئيس ترامب بقى انا بتصور ترامب هو راح
يربح الحزب الجمهوري بالانتخابات
المتحده الامريكيه سابقا لدى الامم
المتحده كانت من المنتقدين لهذا الكتاب هو
تحدث عنها وقال بانها حاكت همم طريقه
لمحاول اثنين همم نيابه الرئاسه او لتكون
رئيس ليست هي فقط من انتقدت وزير الخارجيه
التركي مولود شاويش اوغلو انتقد كذلك هذا
الكتاب وقال بانه همم لانه تحدث عنهم
بوفيه وقال بانه همم هي ديكتاتوريه تركيا
وهم غير قادرون على مواجهه داعش من دون
مساعدتنا كانت هناك انتقادات كذلك من
واشنطن بوست لحساباتهم الخاصه وبالتالي كل
هذه الانتقادات كيف يمكن ان تؤثر اولا على
الداخل الامريكي لاننا نتحدث عن الجهال
وهي من الشخصيات المتابعه وعن الانتخابات
القادمه خاصه
انها كانت ترغب في ان تكون هي نائبا لرئيس
الجمهوريه يعني خلال المرحله المقبله واا
لانه كان متصورا انه يعني سوف يكون ترامب
هو الذي يدخل انتخابات التي فاز فيها بيضا
او ان هو لما يدخل سوف يفوز ولكنه لم يفوز
وفي الحقيقه ترامب رغم
شعبياتها شديده داخل الحزب الجمهوري الا
انها شعبيه يعني تشحب يوما بعد يوم خاصه
بعد انتخابات التجديد النصفي همم انتخابات
التجديد النصفي المرشحين الذين يعني ايدهم
ترامب يعني سقطوا في هذه الانتخابات
بحيث اما ان ترامب سوف يترشح وسوف يحتاجه
بديلا لبنس همم لان برنس الان يريد ان
يترشح في مواجهه ترامب او انها تريد هي
ذاتها ان تترشح للرئاسه همم المعركه الان
جزء منها اعلام يعني لازم ان نعلم انه لا
تزال الليله كما يقال خضراء وبعيده يعني
في في الوقت لا زال هناك حوالي عامين حتى
يوجد كلام جد عن الانتخابات لكن خلال
العامين سوف يحدث احداث كثيره ومن اهمها
ربما صدور هذا الكتاب الذي نتحدث فيه
اليوم لانه همم اكثر همم
ستيتم انت او البيانات تعبيرا عن شخصيه
يمكن ان تكون مرشحه يعني همم الكتاب همم
في جزء كبير بيعبر عن افكار شخصيه سياسيه
هامه واا جزء منها بيتكلم
هو صريح جدا في الفلسفه
الاستاذ عبد الله هذا الكتاب بما حمله من
تصريحات انتقده لبعض وهو فقه هو اي اهو
البعث الاخر الى متى ترى فيه بانه هناك
فكره جديده تطرح تفتح مجال النقاش في
الاتجاهين بعد ان كنا نسمع من داخل
الامريكي اتجاه واحد على الاقل او متشابهه
اتجاهات متشابهه
الكلام الذي هو كلام جديد ومختلف تماما ما
تطرحه الاداره الحاليه في نترات اللي
ملفات المنطقه الملفات الدوليه لمستقبل
المنطقه نحن نتحدثنا عن كثير من لكنه تحدث
ايضا في الكتاب عن عمليه السلام في الشرق
الاوسط عن الاتفاقات الابراهيميه هذه نظره
مهمه جزيلا لك كل النقاش بقيه على كل شكرا
جزيلا لك عبدالله
سعودي شكرا كذلك لدكتور عبد المنعم سعيد
عضو مجلس الشيوخ للاستاذتهم حرب رايس
وتحاله في الامريكيه شرق اساطير
الديمقراطيه ومشاهدين ومتابعينا لنقاش
دائما باقيه السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]